Oh quick so much action oh look at all
the camera shake except it's all fake
hey you want to see a sneak peak of one
of the effects we're using in next
week's video camera shake from a tripod
except this is real camera shake show it
look at how shaky that is cuz it's real
we're gonna try to emulate that in
today's tutorial all right so let's
break down what actually makes camera
motion like seem natural when you're
actually shaking a camera for one you
have several different degrees of
freedom for your camera moving
you have your wrists rotating in
different directions you have your arms
moving your shoulders and your elbows
and your body as a whole so it's several
different variables all attributing to
the same final effect a moving camera so
we're gonna try to emulate that a little
bit with some cascading ly linked null
objects let's try that so first we have
our footage here p on the keyboard
you'll bring up your position and then
if you also click on the stopwatch here
you bring down this like secret code
place to put in formulas and equations
and stuff except it's not nearly that
much so you type in wiggle because
that's scientific and then you put in
two numbers let's say 3 comma 100 and
what these numbers mean is that is three
times per second it'll move 100 pixels
so if I hit enter and now if I preview
it alright it's rotating around and the
first thing we see is like you know
obviously I need to scale this up but
quick tip if you say can't really do
that you can add in this effect called
motion tile if I apply this you can
actually increase your output width and
height and then click Mir edges so that
whenever it gets close to the end of the
frame you get like this kaleidoscope
effect it kind of breaks down if you
have too much motion but if you have
just like a little bit it actually works
remarkably well but since we shot this
in 6k I'm just gonna scale it up so if I
preview this very classic camera shake
in the simplest form but what's wrong
about this is that it's way too simple
it's moving yeah but it's just it seems
very clean in
like made by a computer because it is so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna
actually create a new null object you
can go up to layer new null object and
you're gonna do the same thing for this
one gonna hit key on the keyboard I'm
going to type down wiggle and let's make
this six comma 30 and I'm gonna go back
and edit this first one to be 3 comma 80
so for naming conventions I'm just gonna
label this one hand because I'm gonna
try to simulate what it's like to you
know move your hand which is kind of
faster shorter smaller movements and if
I link this layer to that now it is
moving but it's also tracked to this
other layer that is moving in a
different amount and if we do this one
more time and call this like arms or
something and link that null object to
it hit P I'll click on the stopwatch
type wiggle twice per second move 150
pixels boom now they're all linked
together we have a little bit more
inconsistent motion like lots of
movement here and then it kind of
freezes here and then moves on it's all
very erratic hey I like even but there's
no rotation yet so let's make another
null object and link that final one to
it hit R on the keyboard to bring a
rotation I'll click on the stopwatch and
type in wiggle and this will rotate the
image as a whole so I like to just keep
this at 2 comma 2 you can move it up to
like 4 comma 2 but I wouldn't really go
much more than that if you have too much
rotation looks really funky so let's try
that so now we have a little bit of
rotation I'm gonna call this one's body
because you don't really have too much
motion here but if you're leaning you
have small amounts of rotation with your
body so I mean you can call it whatever
you want so like I said this isn't as
high-quality as the real thing taking a
camera and actually recording something
but let's say you've got to get
something put together in like a minutes
that's not enough time to ply your
camera and actually record something you
can do something like this and as long
as the shots not too long it's pretty
convincing in fact the video that we're
putting out next week on the main
channel has lots of different shots with
camera motion and some of them have
actual real camera tracks but a lot of
the others are really short and it's not
really worth our time to really go in
and actually construct a real camera
shake or that so you know throw on a few
no objects linked to each other moving
at different rates and you get the
chaotic motion that's an
really kind of natural in holding a
camera so this effect kind of breaks
down if you shut longer than just a few
seconds because this the motion kind of
stays really consistent throughout the
entirety of the shot whereas if you have
something tracked with the camera you
can have like you know intense motion
the beginning kind of calm in the middle
and then like a little bit of rotation
at the end you can do that also with
this method it just requires more work
and if you have the time for it sure but
one thing you can do you can make
another null object here and then link
your top null to that one now you have
an actual controller so now you can
actually have baked-in keyframes for a
position scale rotation so some of the
shots we actually used the real camera
tracking data but on a lot of the others
I just did this method because you know
it was easier and it looks just as good
in fact I challenge you to find which
shots are fake versus which ones are not
fake as far as camera motion goes and
hit me up and see how it fared